l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle sur le projet de loire-atif à
la programmation militaire pour les
années 2024 à 2030 et portant diverses
dispositions intéressants la défense
nous allons donc avoir les explications
de vote 5 minutes par orateur et par
groupe politique et le premier d'entre
eux pour le groupe GDR et Monsieur
Fabien Roussel
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission de ce rapporteur mes chers
collègues
413 milliards d'euros pour nos armées
413 milliards d'euros sur 7 ans 69
milliards rien que pour l'année 2030
c'est le doublement du budget militaire
que vous demandez de voter au Parlement
à la demande du Président de la
République qui a théorisé l'idée que la
France devait avoir une guerre d'avance
et participer à la course mondiale à
l'armement
pour financer ce budget découpe claires
sont annoncées dans nos services publics
et les Français sont appelés à se serrer
la ceinture ou à travailler plus
longtemps on va en parler demain
après avoir récolté les dividendes de la
paix c'est aussi l'industrie de
l'armement qui se frotte maintenant les
mains et espère recueillir les
dividendes d'une économie de guerre
car le financement de notre industrie de
défense va aussi dépendre de plus en
plus de l'export de la vente d'armes
dans le monde au risque de nourrir
encore plus les guerres et les conflits
alors oui le débat est sérieux sérieux
car la sécurité de la nation de nos
concitoyens en tout point du territoire
elle est non négociable nous devons
avoir la même exigence de sécurité et de
protection pour tous nos concitoyens
qu'ils habitent dans l'Hexagone mais
aussi en Polynésie aux Antilles en
Guyane ou dans l'océan Indien
nous devons garantir notre autonomie
stratégique protéger la deuxième surface
maritime la plus importante au monde
tout comme nos fonds sous-marins
préserver l'espace de toute
militarisation prévenir les attaques
cyber qui se développent empêcher toute
attaque terroriste être aux côtés de nos
soldats en leur fournissant le meilleur
matériel sans dépendre de technologie de
puissance étrangères tout cela impose du
sérieux et sans arrière pensée
politicienne et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
nous avons fait pendant tout le débat
ici à l'Assemblée nationale
mais monsieur le ministre nous ne nous
retrouvons pas dans cette loi de
programmation militaire dans votre
modèle d'armée qui découle d'une
stratégie militaire toujours au service
de l'OTAN et de la politique étrangère
des États-Unis nous voulons au contraire
garantir l'autonomie stratégique de la
France contribue à celle de l'Europe
vraiment investir dans la diplomatie et
la coopération avec les peuples du monde
tout en assurant à la France les moyens
d'assurer sa défense
avec cette loi de programmation vous
faites le choix avant tout d'investir
dans une armée de projection prête à
faire la guerre partout sans que nous
nous interrogions sur ces 20 dernières
années d'interventionnisme
envoyer nos soldats en Libye en
Afghanistan au Sahel n'a pas fait
reculer le terrorisme et d'ailleurs nos
soldats n'y sont pour rien c'est au
contraire les choix politiques qui les
ont conduit là-bas qui doivent nous
interroger ce modèle expéditionnaire que
vous voulez développer symbolisé par le
porte-avion nouvelle génération à 10
milliards d'euros et non seulement
dangereux politiquement mais en plus il
est coûteux très coûteux les
investissements dans ce porte-avion nous
prive d'investir dans du matériel
militaire tel que des frégates des
patrouilleurs des hélicoptères qui par
exemple seraient nécessaires à la
défense de nos territoires d'outre-mer
et nous ne sommes pas les seuls à le
déplorer certains militaires ont exprimé
leur crainte à ce sujet ce modèle
d’armée que nous ne partageons pas c'est
aussi celui qui fait le choix de
renforcer fortement notre arsenal
nucléaire 54 milliards d'euros au total
près de 8 milliards par an 22 millions
d'euros par jour c'est du jamais vu
alors je le redis ici
à défaut d'avoir une décision de toutes
les puissances nucléaires d'abandonner
cette arme terrible la plus dangereuse
pour l'humanité pour la planète bien sûr
nous disons que la France doit préserver
sa capacité de dissuasion nucléaire nous
le disons mais deux grasses non
rajoutons pas ne participons pas à cette
course à l'armement nucléaire on peut
parler autant que l'on veut d'écologie
de dérèglement climatique mais avec
13000 tête nucléaires dans le monde de
toutes les puissances nucléaires avec
des dizaines de têtes nucléaires qui
circulent 24 heures sur 24 tous les
jours dans les airs dans les mers il y a
de quoi faire sauter plusieurs fois la
planète en quelques secondes pourquoi
investir toujours plus dans des têtes
nucléaires toujours plus meurtrières
alors oui la France a un rôle politique
majeur à jouer et devrait participer aux
prochaines réunions du Traité
d'interdiction de l'arme nucléaire avec
le statut d'observateur
pour conclure plus qu'à une guerre
d'avance cette loi de programmation
militaire nous expose au risque au
risque d'avoir une paix de retard et
c'est la raison pour laquelle malgré des
avancées notables pour nos armées que
nous avons souligné dans le débat les
articles que nous avons voté malgré cela
les députés communistes et GDR votre ont
contre ce texte et souhaite que ce débat
débordent de l'Assemblée nationale pour
que l'ensemble de nos concitoyens sans
saisissent pleinement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
liotte monsieur Christophe nejlaine
c'est le Ministre madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président de commission monsieur le
rapporteur mais chers collègues
le principal en jeu de ce projet de loi
de programmation militaire pour les
années 2024 à 2030 est avant tout il
faut le rappeler la sûreté de notre
concitoyens et de nos territoires de
tout nos territoires il faut bien
entendu et tout le long des débats nous
en avons parlé penser à nos territoires
d'outre-mer qui font le rayonnement de
notre pays pour suivre l'exécution de la
LPM 2019-2025 sans nous remettre en
question aurait relevé de la pâtisserie
stratégique
rappelons-nous que l'un des principaux
échecs de l'entre-deux-guerres a été
l'absence de réformes de la Défense
nationale et la lente désagrégation du
modèle de l'armée jusqu'au blocage
stratégique la LPM 2024 2030 porte deux
ambitions bien distinctes qui adapteront
notre stratégie militaire en ces
différentes capacités stratégiques aux
évolutions appelées de ces vœux par le
chef d'état-major des armées le général
Thierry burqaert le projet de LPM pour
les années 2024 2030 assure une
trajectoire financière de 2 413,3
milliards d'euros pour 13,3 milliards
d'euros de ressources extra budgétaires
pour aussi impressionnant que cela
aurait pu paraître
l'efforts financiers et pourtant absorbé
en partie par deux enveloppes la
dissuasion 20 milliards et l'inflation
30 milliards c'est dans ce cadre
financier que je le disais il nous faut
apprécier non pas une LPM de
transformation mais une LPM d'évolution
qui porte de véritables choix
opérationnels afin d'adapter nos armées
aux évolutions observées depuis la
guerre civile depuis la guerre civile
syrienne et l'intervention russe voire
plus précisément par la guerre faite par
l'Azerbaïdjan à l'armée jusqu'à
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Fédération de Russie en ce sens le
nouveau modèle de l'armée de terre
permettra effectivement de renforcer les
régiment d'appui et ceux de soutien en
prélevant sur les régiments dites de
mêlés artillerie cavalerie infanterie
l'idée maîtresse étant de diminuer leur
vulnabé leur vulnérabilité face aux
nouvelles menaces constatées et de
renforcer leur aptitude à durée sur un
théâtre malgré toutes les atteintes qui
pourraient être portées contre les
différents échelons arrière ou centraux
nous saluons monsieur le ministre votre
engagement à pallier certaines des
sessions effectuées au profit de
l'Ukraine après dépôt de la LPM par de
nouvelles ressources afin de ne pas les
faire peser sur le budget de nos armées
cet LPM a aussi permis le renforcement
de la place et du rôle des
parlementaires dans la définition de
notre politique de défense son examen a
été l'occasion de renforcer le pouvoir
de contrôle des commissaires de la
Défense nationale sur l'exécution de la
LPM ce que nous saluons
c'est en responsabilité que nous
voterons ce texte car il a le courage de
porter des choix l'état des finances il
faut le dire ne nous permet pas
d'avancer puissamment mais le sérieux
stratégique français permet d'entretenir
des armées d'emplois qui sont jugés
crédibles par nos alliés nos adversaires
il faut aussi saluer le plan de 750
millions d'euros mise en place pour les
familles de nos militaires rappeler et
je tiens à le faire devant vous
aujourd'hui leur engagement du quotidien
pour la sécurité de notre la sécurité de
notre pays et penser que quand on est
militaire on s'engage pour les autres et
il serait tout à fait anormal que les
familles ne soient pas traitées comme il
se doit et c'est pour ça que ce plan
famille est important c'est pour ça que
nous devons continuer à investir pour
qu'il puisse vivre de manière convenable
et que lorsque nos militaires sont sur
des théâtres d'opérations extérieurs il
n'est pas en tête la sécurité déjà de
leur famille à l'intérieur même de nos
de nos casernes comme j'ai dit notre
groupe votre a à la quasi unanimité
cette LPM je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
Renaissance monsieur Mounir Bella binti
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues s'il y a un domaine où la
programmation des dépenses sur plusieurs
années est indispensable c'est bien la
défense nationale la conception la
réalisation la livraison et la prise en
main des équipements et des matériels
s'étalent sur plusieurs années la
capacité de notre pays à se défendre ne
peut pas dépendre des éléments de la
conjoncture économique la précédente loi
de programmation militaire peut en ce
domaine faire figure d'exemple malgré
les crises les crises qui ont frappé
notre pays elle a été respectée à l'euro
près après des décennies de coupe
budgétaires notre majorité avait pris et
a tenu l'engagement de réparer nos
armées le texte qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui poursuivra ses efforts
garantir l'efficacité de nos armées
nécessite de la détermination et de la
constance dans l'effort budgétaire sur
la base d'une analyse fine et
panoramique des risques à conjurer ces
risques nous avons pu les mesurer au fil
de nos débats dans une sérénité une
atmosphère de respect mutuel devenu trop
rare dans notre émission une sérénité et
un respect auquel je crois votre sens de
l'écoute a beaucoup contribué monsieur
le ministre peut-être également la
nature des risques et des défis nous
appelle invités collectivement à une
forme de gravité
la réalité géopolitique est complexe et
faite de menaces nouvelles notamment
celle liées aux nouveaux impermédialisme
l'Ukraine et le terrain d'expression de
ce phénomène qui menace l'Europe tout
entière
les conflits sont aujourd'hui hybrides
il nous faut donc assurer la protection
de nos citoyens et de nos intérêts sur
ces nouveaux espaces de conflictualité
de l'espace exo-atmosphérique au fond
marin en passant évidemment par le cyber
pour cela il nous faut bien évidemment
renforcer nos armées la trajectoire
budgétaire de 413 milliards d'euros sur
7 ans que nous nous apprêtons à voter y
répondre mes chers collègues il n'est
pas d'armée sans principe ni doctrine ce
projet de loi inscrit notre défense
nationale dans une logique d'alliance
qui depuis des décennies par de l'AS les
alternances politiques fondent notre
stratégie diplomatique et de défense la
dissuasion nucléaire clé de vote de
notre défense et de notre souveraineté
en sortira renforcée avec notamment la
construction d'un porte-avions nucléaire
de nouvelles générations et des
sous-marins nucléaires lanceurs d'engins
de troisième génération ils assureront
la crédibilité de notre dissuasion
corollaire indispensable de notre
sécurité
nos choix d'équipements réaffirment
aussi notre modèle d'armée complet en
répondant au défi des conflits
d'aujourd'hui par l'acquisition de
nouveaux véhicules terrestres de rafale
de dernière génération de munitions de
drones c'est tout cela dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui notre sécurité les moyens de
notre sécurité en votant ce texte il
nous faut également répondre à une
interrogation de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens tant d'argent pour l'armée
est-ce bien raisonnable la question est
légitime elle mérite une réponse notre
réponse repose sur une réalité simple
mais implacable la paix et la condition
de la survie de notre modèle social et
la paix pour être préservée doit être
garantie par un effort de la défense à
la hauteur des risques le budget annuel
de nos armées aura certes plus que
doublé entre 2017 et 2030 c'est le prix
à payer pour notre sécurité après qu'il
convient de comparer à ce que la France
consacre à sa protection sociale la
réalité c'est que notre pays chaque
année dépense 14 fois plus pour la la
protection sociale des citoyens que pour
la défense nationale les dépenses
militaires que nous nous apprêtons à
voter constitue en outre un facteur
puissant de développement économique et
technologique les investissements
inscrits dans la loi de programmation
militaire irrigueront l'ensemble de
notre secteur industrielle de défense
favorisant et accélérant la
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
par notre vote d'aujourd'hui nous
contribuerons également à l'amélioration
des conditions faites à nos militaires à
leur famille ainsi qu'aux civils de la
défense
financer cet effort pour la défense
suppose une économie puissante car tout
se tient le retour aux plein emploi la
croissance de l'économie dégage de
nouvelles recettes publiques et c'est
aussi parce que des réformes de nos
comptes publics sont menées réforme
nécessaires à défaut d'être toujours
populaire que la France pourra dégager
dans la durée les moyens de financer ses
dépenses d'avenir cette LPM s'inscrit
donc dans un projet politique cohérent
le groupe Renaissance votera bien
évidemment pour cette loi de
programmation militaire 2024-2030 avec
l'espoir de rassembler le plus grand
nombre de nos collègues autour de cette
ambition pour la France
parce que chacun sait bien que pour
garantir la défense d'un pays au-delà
des moyens financiers des choix
technologiques des modes d'organisation
il est un impératif une condition
préalable à tout l'unité de la nation
autour de ces armées
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
du Rassemblement national Monsieur
Laurent jacobelli
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
que les effectifs et les budgets de nos
armées ont été taillés par les
gouvernements successifs de toute
tendance de droite de gauche ou du
centre nos armées ont été meurtries par
des décennies de coupe budgétaire et
d'abandon en race campagne il s'agit là
de l'oeuvre de dirigeants au profil de
gestionnaire étriqué mais sûrement pas
de visionnaire
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le courage
de nos militaires qui malgré cela ont
continué d'accomplir leur mission
admirablement il devenait être urgent
d'inverser la tendance et l'actuel et le
PM a commencé à le faire oui notre
nation a besoin d'une oie de
programmation militaire ambitieuse à la
hauteur de l'engagement des hommes et
des femmes qui font nos armées et à la
hauteur des dangers qui nous menacent je
souhaiterais tout d'abord saluer ici
monsieur le rapporteur et Monsieur le
Ministre car vous avez su travailler
avec l'ensemble des groupes de cette
assemblée non débat ont pour une fois je
crois fait honneur à cette enceinte ça a
pas dû être simple monsieur le ministre
entre une majorité peu habituée au
dialogue des LR absents et une nupaisse
dispersée façon puzzle sur les questions
essentielles que sont l'Europe de la
défense est nucléaire mais nous y sommes
arrivés
vous devriez d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre expliqué ce qu'est la
démocratie du parlementaire à vos
collègues Darmanin le maire du soft ou
autre Dupont-Moretti et si j'osais vous
devriez aussi donner des cours
particuliers à Madame borne car une fois
n'est pas coutume vous avez entendu et
intégré certaines de nos propositions
comme par exemple la révision à la
hausse de la grille indiciaire ou encore
la rénovation d'urgence d'hébergement et
de lieux de vie qui abrite nos soldats
quant à la stratégie de placer la
dissuasion nucléaire au cœur de notre
défense et d'y mettre les moyens c'est
vous le savez un point essentiel du
programme de Marine Le Pen en matière de
défense mais le tableau n'est pas si
rose monsieur le ministre augmenter les
effectifs améliorer l'entraînement
accroître les moyens capacitaires c'est
très bien et c'est ce que nous voulions
mais pourquoi faire défendre la France
et les Français notre souveraineté ou
bien au contraire préparer la
dissolution de notre défense dans une
défense européenne fantasmée
car pour faire un cadeau aux écologistes
radicaux vous avez cédé à la fable de la
défense européenne une défense dont
personne ne veut à l'étranger comme en
France hormis peut-être trois députés de
la majorité Emmanuel Macron deux
écologistes et ce qui reste des
socialistes vouloir une Europe de la
défense quand nous alliés achètent
américain ou coréen quand nos
coopérations avec l'Allemagne comme le
Scaff ou le mgcs patine cette illusoire
c'est naïf et c'est même dangereux
vouloir laisser les clés de la défense à
l'Europe mais mes chers collègues de la
majorité vous n'avez donc pas tiré les
leçons de vos erreurs vous lui avez
laissé les clés pour gérer l'immigration
regardez le résultat vous lui avez
confié le prix de l'énergie c'est un
désastre vous l'avez laissé gérer les
échanges commerciaux c'est une
catastrophe fiasco fiasco fiasco ils ont
tout raté alors non nous ne laisserons
pas les Européens confisqués aux
Français les clés de leurs défenses
vous-même monsieur le ministre vous avez
dû batailler pour contenir ceux de votre
propre majorité qui voulait tout
européaniser même notre souveraineté
quelle épreuve cela a dû être pour
quelqu'un qui se réclame du gaullisme
alors c'est l'heure des choix pour le
groupe rassemblement national votez
cette loi de programmation militaire ou
ne pas la voter pour trancher cette
question nous nous sommes demandés si
cette loi était compatible ou non avec
le projet de Marine Le Pen pour 2027
vous vouliez vous défaussez sur vos
successeurs en repoussant la clause de
revoyure et les principales marches
budgétaires à 2027 et bien chiche nous
relevons le défi cela sera l'occasion
pour nous de réorienter cette LPM pour
garantir notre souveraineté nationale
contrôler les coopérations européennes
et relocaliser l'industrie de défense
vous avez repoussé l'essentiel des
hausses investissements après 2027 et
bien nous ferons bon usage de cet argent
pour une armée mieux équipée mieux
entraînée et des soldats mieux
considérés c'est pourquoi sans
enthousiasme avec vigilance mais aussi
avec la satisfaction de voir un certain
nombre de nos mesures adoptées nous
voterons pour cette loi de programmation
militaire avec il faut dire de
véritables morceaux de RN dedans mais
sans jamais oublier que le seul intérêt
qui nous anime c'est celui de la défense
de notre nation la France et de ceux qui
la font vivre je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
de la France insoumise monsieur Aurélien
Saintoul
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur collègue une loi
de programmation militaire n'est pas un
texte comme les autres on ne peut se
prononcer à son sujet sans avoir à
l'esprit les hommes et femmes de la
défense soldat et civils techniciens
ingénieur et ouvriers dont l'héroïsme et
l'ardeur à la peine suscite notre
respect notre gratitude et notre
admiration
à l'hommage que nous leur rendons je
veux aussi adjoindre mes remerciements
au ministre dont la façon d'agir
contraste si nettement avec la brutalité
et l'anti parlementarisme ordinaire du
gouvernement il a créé les conditions
d'un débat d'ignumenté qui nous permet
de prendre acte des convergences comme
des désaccords sans procéder d'intention
ni remarque infamante c'est des accords
sont les biens les plus précieux de la
démocratie ils en sont la fin et le
moyen c'est pour se garder la
possibilité d'un des accords respectueux
que nos militaires infinés s'engagent et
c'est la vitalité de la controverse
démocratique qui nourrit la force morale
indispensable pour faire face aux crises
et aux conflits
dès lors je dois dire nos désaccords et
pour cela je vous prie collègue de
considérer le monde tel qu'il était il y
a vingt années vous aurez ainsi une idée
des transformations qu'il attendent dans
les 20 prochaines souvenez-vous 2003 est
un autre monde un monde où les modem
Grésilles ou les États-Unis envahissent
les races ou la France souffre d'une
canicule encore inédite où le sera se
fait son apparition ou le Concorde
quitte le service et où le Rafale prend
à peine le sien un monde où Vladimir
Poutine a finalement bonne presse dans
les chancelleries un monde dans lequel
le capitalisme se délocalise sans
crainte en Chine la distance avec notre
monde n'est rien comparée à celle qui se
placera entre 2023 et 2043 pour faire
face et garantir à notre pays de pouvoir
encore s'y faire entendre et se défendre
il ne peut s'agir de faire la même chose
avec plus de moyens il faut nous
projeter et cette LPM ne le fait pas
elle intervient alors que l'ancienne LPM
courte encore nous avions deux ans nous
avons toujours deux ans pour proposer
une véritable loi de planification et de
protection de la souveraineté c'est une
occasion ratée le saupoudrage va se
poursuivre nos entreprises resteront
vulnérables au rachat hostile nous
continuerons d'importer certains des
composants les plus critiques de nos
systèmes d'armes le contrôle
démocratique sur le commerce des armes
va rester balbutiant et nous resterons
hélastributaire de dictatures comme
l’égypte ou le Tchad au sujet duquel
monsieur le ministre vous avez refusé de
répondre avec ce texte quel est votre
objectif le plus clair la revue
nationale stratégique ce texte fluait
nous l'apprend être et demeurer un allié
exemplaire mais comment cela pourrait-il
suffire nous disons nous que nous devons
être indépendants et refuser
l'alignement proposer une voie tierce au
peuple qui refuse l'embrigadement au
service d'un quelconque hégémonisme
parce qu'en définitive l'intérêt de la
France c'est celui de l'humanité la paix
alors que la crise écologique va
susciter toutes sortes de
déstabilisation et de conflits du fait
des pénuries vous remettez à deux mains
l'objectif indispensable à urgent
préparez la pré pétrole de même vous
préférez camper sur l'assurance que la
dissuasion nucléaire est crédible
aujourd'hui plutôt que de travailler à
une alternative à l'horizon de plusieurs
décennies si jamais elle venait à ne
plus l'être
pour étoffer notre modèle d'armée vous
faites le choix de la réserve et pour
atteindre vos objectifs de recrutement
il vous faudra d'abord généraliser le
SNU ce gadget folklorique est le spectre
qui en de votre LPM et une menace de
plusieurs milliards qui planent
au-dessus de votre programmation
budgétaire vous avez repoussé les
objectifs capacidaires de la capacité de
la précédente LPM pour faire un peu de
place au secteur que nous disions
prioritaire il y a déjà 5 ans les
nouvelles frontières de l'humanité que
sont l'espace la mer et le cyber mais
dans ces domaines aussi en réalité les
ambitions seront finalement limitées je
veux aussi évoquer les outre-mer ils
auraient dû être le point de départ de
la réflexion il ne s'agit pas d'une case
à cocher mais d'une spécificité qui fait
de la France une nation universelle la
Riveraine de tous les océans la voisine
de tous les peuples la porte-parole
d'une cause qu'il a dépasse mais les
outre-mer demeurent plutôt considérés
comme un point d'appui un patrimoine que
comme la France elle-même
arrivé au terme du débat je veux redire
notre gratitude envers nos soldats nous
serons vigilants et pressants pour que
leur quotidien s'améliore et les
familles mieux accompagnées il y a
encore trop d'incertitudes autour de
l'avenir du service de santé des armées
et nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi les
avancées que nous proposons pour les
blessés psychiques ont encore été
écartés pour toutes ces raisons nous
voterons contre
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
la parole est un monsieur Jean-Louis
Thieriot
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues au début
de la discussion générale de cette LPM
j'avais dit que cette loi n'était pas
historique mais qu'elle était
raisonnable aujourd'hui elle est plus
raisonnable encore une loi historique
cela aurait été de retrouver le niveau
de la guerre froide 3% du PIB alors que
nous ne serons qu'à deux pour cent
monsieur Poutine est certainement aussi
dangereux que Monsieur brejnef une loi
historique selon a été de réécrire nos
contrats opérationnels pour disposer de
davantage de moyens érotéresses
notamment avec des moyens organiques de
niveau corde armée ou une flotte dotée
de davantage de navires de premier rang
une loi historique aurait exigée au
moins 40 milliards complémentaires mais
nous savons l'état de nos finances
publiques tant que nous n'aurons pas
défini une trajectoire soutenable 413
milliards d'euros ce n'est déjà pas si
mal vous avez fait le choix monsieur le
ministre de la cohérence sur la masse
cette olpm renforce la dissuasion
garantit une armée réellement
opérationnelle traite des nouveaux
champs de conflictualité sauvegarde les
grands programmes assurent la
préparation de l'avenir c'est une copie
qui n'est pas sans mairie elle préserve
la sécurité de la France même si elle ne
nous offre pas la possibilité de gagner
en influence lorsque l'on voit le gain
politique de notre présence en Roumanie
ou en Estonie que jussémée que nos
contrats opérationnels nous permissent
de faire de même avec nos amis polonais
par exemple
quel marqueur fort qui aurait permis de
peser davantage sur l'échiquier européen
cela étant durant ces débats nous avons
obtenu beaucoup monsieur le ministre
vous nous avez écouté et vous avez donné
un avis favorable à une vingtaine de nos
amendements avec un respect qui pourrait
servir de modèle à d'autres textes en
ces temps de majorité relative nous
avons obtenu l'engagement de budgétiser
les 13 milliards de ressources extra
budgétaires s'il devait ne pas être à la
hauteur de l'espérance c'est essentiel
c'est une garantie de sincérité qui fait
l'unanimité et nous permet de parler
avec certitude d'une LPM de 413
milliards nous avons obtenu qu'un
rapport du Parlement si le point sur le
SCAP et le mgcs avant les engagements
budgétaires nous avons obtenu pour nous
outre-mer le lancement d'un nouveau
programme de bâtiments amphibie battral
et des études sur un port en eau
profondes à Mayotte nous avons obtenu
une attention particulière aux
financement de notre BITD avec notamment
la création d'un médiateur du crédit
défense alors oui notre groupe votera
cette LPM mais ce n'est pas un chèque en
blanc
vous n'avez pas accepté de faire évoluer
les marches une LPM est un subtile à
semblable qui dépend des contrastes
opérationnelles loin de moi l'idée de la
bouleverser en visant des cibles
capacitaires qui aligneraient davantage
l'avion ou blindé pour ce bercer des
illusions de la puissance en revanche
nous avons déploré que l'optimum de la
préparation opérationnelle ne fut
atteint qu'en 2030 l'entraînement c'est
le quotidien du soldat vous vous êtes
engagé à produire lors de la navette
parlementaire au Sénat des informations
sur ce point pour examiner comment
l'améliorer c'est là qu'un effort sur
les marches aurait tout son sens nous
avons entendu vos ouvertures de la copie
qui sortira de la chambre haute dépendra
notre position finale en CMP mais avant
d'achever je veux saluer la qualité de
nos débats elle tient à la gravité de la
matière parce que de décision il y a des
hommes et des femmes qui se battent
parfois jusqu'à l'ultime sacrifice tout
au long de nos travaux j'avais en tête
un majeur du Commando Hubert qui sur la
plage arrière de la frégate à comique me
parler de deux de ses frères d'armes
tombés au Burkina Faso dans une
opération de libération de tâches
ensemble nous avons mesuré nous avons
murmuré la prière des parents celle de
l'aspirantheld mon Dieu donne-moi ce
dont les autres ne veulent pas en
pensant à lui je pense à la compagnie
des ombres qui nous a accompagnés tout
au long de nos débats celle de nos
collègues d'Abel ferry au colonel Driant
qui comme des millions de Français ont
fait le sacrifice de leur vie
je pense surtout à ceux qui sont tombés
ces dernières années à leurs frères
d'armes au veuves aux orphelins aux
parents et à nos blessés qui luttent
contre la souffrance physique ou morale
je crois qu'en ayant débattu comme nous
l'avons fait et en votant aujourd'hui
cette LPM nous témoignons en toute
humilité le respect qui est dû à ceux
qui ont tout donné
merci pour le groupe
démocrate la parole est à Madame
josipoeto
merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
le Ministre mais Madame et Monsieur
parce qu'il ne rapporte madame et
monsieur le rapporteur messieurs les
monsieur le Président de la Commission
et chers collègues nous voilà arrivés au
terme des débats de cette loi de
programmation militaire 2024 2030 et je
me réjouis avec l'ensemble des députés
du groupe démocrate
du travail de qualité que nous avons
tous menée nous avons eu des débats
constructifs et intéressants nous
n'étions pas toujours d'accord sur le
fond mais nous avons réussi à mener ce
travail collectivement et avec sérieux
tant nous étions convaincus de la grande
mission qui nous incombait garantir un
modèle d'armée ambitieux pour l'avenir
et des moyens à mettre en œuvre pour
atteindre cet objectif
je tiens ici à remercier nos deux
rapporteurs Jean-Michel Jacques pour la
commission de la défense et Sabine pour
la commission des lois vous avez
effectué un travail de grande qualité en
amont et tout au long de l'examen de
cette proposition de loi je remercie
également monsieur le ministre qui a été
présente durant tous les débats en
commission et en hémicycle ainsi que les
deux secrétaires d'états vous vous êtes
montré disponible à l'écoute vous avez
contribué au bon déroulées des
discussions et je tiens à saluer votre
recherche du consensus qui a favorisé
l'implication de tous les groupes
contrairement à ce que nous avons pu
entendre parfois au cours des débats il
n'y a pas eu de renoncement dans cette
programmation c'est une LPM qui prend en
compte l'ensemble de notre territoire et
tout particulièrement nos outre-mer qui
méritent une présence une protection
renforcée c'est aussi une LPM ambitieuse
et cohérente qui demande un effort
important à la nation mais qui nous
permettra de renforcer considérablement
la
[Musique]
indépendance de notre continent et de la
France avec ses partenariats solides
nous renforçons l'interopérabilité de
nos armées et l'autonomie stratégique
européenne nous avons aussi été très
vigilant sur la question des réserves
nous sommes convaincus que le
renforcement de notre modèle d'armée et
de la résilience de notre nation face
aux crises passe par l'engagement de nos
concitoyens notre groupe a donc porté
plusieurs amendements visant à
accompagner la montée en puissance de la
réserve opérationnelle étendre les
possibilités de s'engager et valoriser
songagement pour renforcer le lien armée
nation nous avons mis en avant
l'importance de l'engagement et de la
communication autour des réserves et du
SMU permettez-moi de saluer ici
Christophe Blanchet pour sa mobilisation
sur le sujet
le groupe démocrate a également défendu
l'amélioration des conditions de vie de
nos militaires et de leur famille dans
cette LPM marque notre reconnaissance
envers celle et ceux qui risquent leur
vie pour défendre notre nation mais
aussi en verse ceux qui vivent avec eux
et qui acceptent les conséquences de
l'engagement opérationnel il ne doivent
pas être oubliés et c'est pourquoi nous
avons porté plusieurs amendements visant
à une meilleure reprise en compte de ces
familles de militaires j'y suis
personnellement attaché avec mes
collègues de la commission défense enfin
grâce au pouvoir de contrôle dans le
Parlement disposera et à la clause de
revoyure en 2027 nous veillerons à
l'application de chacun de ces objectifs
sur le long terme ainsi chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris cette loi est
nécessaire nous armées en ont besoin
pour engager leur transformation il en
va de notre défense et de notre sécurité
nationale la transformation du contexte
stratégique et la guerre en Ukraine nous
impose de définir une nouvelle
trajectoire pour nos armées nous devons
être capables de détecter et participer
les menaces actuelles et futures et de
nous en protéger c'est une programmation
budgétaire cohérente qui nous permettra
de garder notre rang en puissance
d'équilibre capable de mener une
coalition internationale nous avons tous
fait des concessions chaque groupe a pu
inscrire dans cette LPM des dispositions
qui lui tenaient à cœur et nous pouvons
être satisfaits du travail accompli pour
nos armées reconnaissant de l'engagement
sans faille de nos militaires au service
de la nation le groupe démocrate votera
évidemment en faveur de ce texte et nous
vous invitons chers collègues à être
cohérents comme les 7 lois et à voter
également en faveur de cette LPM
historique je vous remercie madame la
députée
alors
chers collègues il vous reste quelques
instants pour tenir vos conversations
privées en dehors de l'hémicycle ce qui
nous permettra d'écouter dans le calme
pour 5 minutes et pour le groupe
socialiste madame Mélanie Thomas
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des Armées madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
défense madame messieurs les rapporteurs
au nom du groupe socialiste et à parenté
je souhaite saluer tous ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien au service de
la nation militaire civil de la défense
salarié de l'industrie
chers collègues nous voici réunis pour
nous prononcer sur le projet de loi de
programmation militaire feuille de route
pour nos armées jusqu'à la fin de la
décennie ce document législatif
fondateur au service de notre sécurité
et de nos intérêts vitaux je voudrais
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre saluez
votre effort constant de répondre aux
interrogations du Parlement dans le
cadre de ce débat dans un contexte
d'affirmation des puissances dans un
monde en profonde mutation avec des
ruptures technologiques majeures cet LPM
constitue une étape d'affirmation pour
la nation française
affirmer notre profond attachement au
coopération européenne au sein de
l'Alliance atlantique avec nos
partenaires géographiques affirmer
ensuite notre politique de dissuasion
nucléaire qui représente en premier lieu
une garantie la garantie de la paix sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
européen au sein de ce débat nous avons
des points d'entente que plusieurs de
commandements adopté sont venus
alimenter des points de renforcement et
d'affirmation de notre souveraineté
nationale dans l'industrie de défense
pour nos services de renseignement dans
la lutte contre les influences
étrangères dans la protection de nos
interviews vitaux sur terre en mer sous
la mer si ces points de compromis
existent il ne suffisent pas à élider un
certain nombre de nos divergences dans
les médias vous avez annoncé que cette
LPM est aussi historique ambitieuse il
est vrai monsieur le ministre que le
gouvernement investit 413 milliards
d'euros pour nos armées cela témoigne
d'une réelle volonté d'action dans ce
cas pourquoi cette LPM historiquement
ambitieuse reporte son effort financier
massif après 2027 l'effort ne devrait-il
pas intervenir dès le début de la
programmation et nous au début du mandat
présidentiel suivant rappelons que les
413 milliards annoncés inclus plusieurs
éléments dont 30 milliards consacré à
absorber l'inflation 100 milliards de
reste à charge de dépenses déjà engagées
ceci ramènent l'effort réel bien en deçà
de la Somme historique annoncée monsieur
le ministre à cet égard nos doutes
persistent nécessité d'un choc
indiciaire c'est dans ces termes que le
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
militaire a formulé les attentes des
personnels on risque sa vie pour la
nation mais pour qu'elle reconnaissances
à l'unanimité les représentants des
personnels pointent l'urgente nécessité
d'améliorer leur pouvoir d'achat quelle
valorisation pour ces personnels en
mobilité chronique qui subissent la
crise du logement comment moderniser les
infrastructures de nos bases nous nous
félicitons du plan famille du plan
blessé dispositif pérenne qui vont
concrètement mieux les accompagner mais
comment résoudre les grands enjeux de
fidélisation pérenniser les carrières
limiter la contractualisation contourner
la fuite vers le privé la crise
n'épargne pas les militaires et les
civils de la défense
en matière capacitaire ce projet nous
semble manquer d'ambition et les
orientations proposées ne nous semblent
pas dessiner un modèle d'armée suffisant
déshabiller Pierre pour habiller Paul en
démobrant certains de nos régiments
chars infanterie au profit d'autres
branches de nos armées nous devons
questionner notre capacité à nous
engager dans un conflit de haute
intensité sommes-nous aujourd'hui aptes
apporter les standard d'une nation cadre
à piloter l'effort de guerre européen
la guerre revenue sur notre continent
cette LPM représente un moment de
réflexion dans un contexte géopolitique
durablement marqué puisque nous sommes
la deuxième nation maritime du monde il
faut nous donner les moyens de nos
ambitions politiques économiques
environnementales l'actualité
quotidienne nous rappelle que les
tensions sont vives sur les mers du
globe pour contrôler piller les
ressources que notre nation s'engage à
protéger parce que l'urgence climatique
est désormais une réalité nous devons
aussi anticiper ses conséquences dans
des situations d'instabilité qui
supposent notre responsabilité
l'absence de livres blancs ne nous
permet pas de comprendre le récit
fondateur de vos choix stratégiques dans
un contexte chahuté comment se raconter
comment s'affirmer quelle priorité pour
nos armées nous avons besoin de tirer
les leçons du conflit ukrainien
monsieur le ministre si nous partageons
plusieurs affirmations fortes pour nos
armées nous n'avons pas trouvé de
réponse satisfaisante à des
questionnements majeurs notre vote
intervient à l'issue d'une première
lecture et l'examen de ce projet de loi
bascule désormais au Sénat nos collègues
du groupe socialiste vous ont déjà
transmis une série de plusieurs
questions nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à vos réponses au regard de
l'ensemble de ces éléments les députés
socialistes s'absciendront
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci madame la députée alors je fais
annoncer le scrutin il y a encore deux
orateurs essayer sincèrement chers
collègues de limiter vos propos privés
le bruit est très agréable pour les
orateurs donc je fais annoncer le
scrutin et je passe la parole pour le
groupe horizon pour 5 minutes à
Jean-Charles larsener
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame monsieur les ministres madame
monsieur les rapporteurs monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues nous
achetons aujourd'hui un marathon de
quatre semaines sur ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire nous pouvons
nous féliciter de la bonne tenue des
débats mais aussi de leur exhaustivité
tous les groupes dans cette hémicycle
ont eu l'opportunité de défendre leur
vision parfois contradictoires de la
place de la France dans le monde à
travers ses alliances et ses choix
géostratégiques pour les sept prochaines
années
nous faisons le choix de renouveler
notre engagement auprès de nos
partenaires européens et atlantiques qui
nous engagaient tout aussi résolument en
faveur de la modernisation de notre
dissuasion nucléaire et du
renouvellement d'un modèle d'armée
robuste et cohérent adapté à des
engagements plus durs
notre groupe se félicite de réels
avancées que nous avons obtenu sur ce
texte avec la majorité et bien souvent
dans un esprit constructif avec les
différentes sensibilités représentées
dans cette assemblée ses avancées elles
concernent d'abord et avant tout les
femmes et les hommes qui se battent
chaque jour pour préserver notre
sécurité et celle de nos alliés parfois
jusqu'au sacrifice suprême
pour les militaires leur conjoint leurs
enfants nous avons porté haut les
ambitions du plan famille 2 c'est un
investissement durable de 750 millions
d'euros au plus près des territoires et
de notre collectivité nos militaires
seront ainsi mieux protégés en cas de
blessure ou de maladies en opération
extérieure ces dernières seront
désormais considérées imputables au
service dès le premier jour passer sur
un théâtre d'opération
mais de réelles progrès ont aussi été
consentis pour notre base industrielle
et technologique de défense nos
capacités notre résidence cyber et pour
le contrôle parlementaire dans
l'exécution de ce projet de loi
pour notre BITD nous assumons une
orientation vers l'innovation de rupture
tente au sein des grands groupes qu'au
sein des petites et moyennes entreprises
il importe que les armées profitent des
innovations
issues des entreprises du monde civil
par exemple de la part des opérateurs de
satellite l'état pourra de même
faciliter le financement des entreprises
de la défense en facilitant
l'orientation des investissements privés
et l'épargne des Français vers notre
bittv chers
donc vous écoutez monsieur l'arsener
puis encore une oratrice et nous
parlerons en vote donc sincèrement ayez
un peu de respect pour l'orateur chacun
a envie d'être écouté dans un minimum de
silence allez-y monsieur parce que notre
BITD ne peut être souveraine et
dynamique que grâce à la combinaison de
commande publique et de l'export nous
garantissons sur le volet capacitaire à
la fois une montée en puissance au
niveau national et des partenariats
renforcés au niveau européen
grâce à cette assemblée nos armées
bénéficieront d'une filière souveraine
dans la protection des fonds marins et
de navires de projection de force pour
nos outre-mer nous aurons aussi en 2028
une étude évaluant la possibilité de
construire un deuxième porte-avion de
nouvelles générations
nous renouvelons enfin
résolument et sans naïveté les
partenariats privilégiés avec nos alliés
les plus proches la Belgique l'Italie
l'Espagne la Grèce l'Allemagne et le
Royaume-Uni
cette montée en puissance dans une
logique de cohérence consent à des
efforts prioritaires parmi lesquels le
nécessaire développement de notre
résilience cyber pour cette dernière
nous avons ajouté de nombreuses
garanties afin que les nouvelles
prérogatives accordées à l'annecy
protège au mieux les données des
utilisateurs des réseaux mais c'est
aussi pour nous parlementaire que nous
avons su enrichir ce texte afin de
renforcer notre pouvoir de contrôle dans
l'exécution de cette loi de
programmation militaire
son actualisation donnera lieu à un vote
et les commissions chargées de la
Défense dans les deux chambres seront
impliquées plus en amont dans les
ajustements annuels qui auront lieu dans
chaque loi de finance mes chers
collègues ne nous voilons pas la face
nous sommes confrontés à des stratégies
d'affirmation de puissance accrues et à
de dangereux révisionnisme depuis le 24
février 2022 la guerre d'agression est
de retour sur notre continent de
nouvelles conflictualités se font jour à
l'aise de l'Europe en Afrique et dans
l'espace indopacifique enfin la menace
terroriste n'a pas disparu loin de là
nous avons donc le devoir pour protéger
nos concitoyens de l'Hexagone comme des
Outre-mer de consentir cet effort
important pour nos armées c'est aussi la
garantie que la France restera un
partenaire incontournable en Europe et à
l'international le Groupe horizon et
apparenté approuvent pleinement cet
effort nécessaire et votre a donc sans
hésitation ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur le député je ne sais pas
trop sur quel ton le demander mais il y
a une oratrice encore vous avez vous
faites tous des conversations privées
essayez d'écouter dans le silence pour 5
minutes la présidente du groupe
écologiste madame Cyrielle châtelain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègues nous ne pouvons pas ignorer le
climat particulier dans lequel s'inscrit
cette fois de programmation suite à
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
la guerre frappe à nouveau l'Europe hier
nous apprenions la destruction d'un
barrage en Ukraine un acte qualifié par
le Secrétaire général de l'ONU ont Tonio
guteres de catastrophe humanitaire
économique et écologique monumentale dès
le début de l'invasion russe les
écologistes ont plaidés pour que la
France et l'Europe s'engagent
concrètement pour aider l'Ukraine à
maintenir sa souveraineté ce qui passe
notamment par l'envoi d'armes de
matériel de défense et de matériel de
secours ne vous y trompez pas
les écologistes n'ont pas à oublier
leurs engagements pacifistes et
humanistes au contraire lorsqu'il s'agit
de faire face à une agression militaire
à des crimes de guerre à l'attaque d'un
autre chat contre nos valeurs et que
tout un peuple nous hésiterons pas à
prendre nos responsabilités et je suis
sûr que cette séance peut faire silence
pendant une minute au moins pour écouter
ce que nous avons à dire sur la Russie
et sur l'Ukraine et pour nos militaire
alors oui je vous le dis c'est dans un
esprit de responsabilité que les
écologistes ont travaillé sur cette loi
de programmation et je souhaite
remercier la capacité d'écoute et de
débats dont un préférure monsieur le
ministre nous avons eu un temps pour
confronter nos analyses pour exposer nos
divergences je pense par exemple à nos
échanges sur la dissuasion nucléaire qui
fait bien trop souvent l'objet d'un
évitement démocratique l'inscription du
traité de mon prolifération dans le
rapport indexé est un symbole fort bien
sûr pour les écologistes nous pensons
qu'il faut avancer encore plus
clairement sur une position pour aboutir
à une décision d'interdiction
multilatérale de ces armes mais oui
c'est une avancée les écologistes
portent une vision humaniste de la
sécurité la défense ne se limite pas à
l'outil militaire la paix comme la
stabilité se construisent politiquement
en prenant en compte les aspects
diplomatiques sociaux économiques qui
traversent les questions géopolitiques
la vision que nous défendons est
développée depuis 1994 par l'ONU au
travers du concept de sécurité humaine
cette logique de sécurité humaine permet
d'intégrer plus fortement la logique des
droits humains et de protection des
populations c'est pourquoi nous avons
défendu l'augmentation des moyens pour
les diplomaties
aujourd'hui cette approche de sécurité
humaine permet de mieux répondre aux
nouvelles insécurités de ce siècle qui
se limite pas au conflit étatique
terrorisme trouble socio-économique
catastrophes naturelles climatiques
pandémie la LPM comporte trop de points
aveugles sur ces questions c'est
pourquoi nous regrettons que c'est toi
sont une opportunité ratée de
véritablement d'adapter véritablement
nos défenses au défi de notre temps la
question du climat en est l'exemple
majeur malgré des avancées certes mais
qui restent extrêmement timides les
bouleversements stratégiques majeurs
entraînés par le changement climatique
sont largement sous-estimés les efforts
de résilience et de sobriété nos armées
pour décaronner leurs activités et
limiter leurs usages de ressources en
voie de raréfaction sous bien trop
timide un autre motif de regret ne nous
quitte pas vous le savez les écologistes
sont pleinement engagés sur l'Europe de
la défense oui il y a eu des avancées
par rapport grâce à nos amendements mais
aujourd'hui cela reste bien trop timide
nous le disons seule une Europe de la
défense et le chemin pour que l'Europe
et la France conservent une voix forte
dans le monde avant l'agression russe
l'épée de l'Union européenne disposait
de 2 millions de personnes sous
uniformes et consacré 200 milliards
d'euros par an par la défense
collectivement cela représente un tiers
des dépenses mondiales imaginez les
gains d'efficacité et les gains
financiers ou bien opérationnels que
représenterait cette Europe de la
défense aujourd'hui c'est l'un des
outils de garantir la stabilité et la
paix dans le monde enfin nous vous
devons quand même parler de politique
budgétaire puisque c'est une loi de
programmation budgétaire cette loi
effectivement fait en plus plus 118
milliards d'euros sur six années en
faveur de l'armée oui c'est un besoin
vital nous ne le contestons pas mais des
besoins vitaux il y en a tellement et si
l'armée a besoin d'investissement nous
plaidons également pour qu'il y ait des
investissements dans l'ensemble des
autres besoins vitaux de notre état
l'école publique l'hôpital est bien
évidemment l'investissement pour la
transition écologique aujourd'hui vous
posez une loi de programmation des
finances publiques mais vous venez en
incapacité d'avoir une majorité pour
voter vos lois de règlement vous êtes en
incapacité pour avoir une loi de
programmation financière donc nous le
disons vous avez une solution pour avoir
une majorité elle se trouve dans les
investissements investissez autant dans
l'armée que dans l'école dans l'hôpital
dans la transition énergétique et vous
trouverez une majorité vous l'aurez
compris les écologistes voteront
responsabilité ils savent sera un grand
mais aujourd'hui il reste encore de
nombreux regrets sur cette voie de
programmation militaire
merci madame la Présidente je ne sais
pas si je dois me réjouir de voir vos
appels au silence aussi peu entendu que
les miens nous allons donc passer au
vote donc mettre aux voix le projet de
loi tout le monde est évidemment à sa
place
c'est un scrutin public
il a été annoncé le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos et voici le résultat
du scrutin
votant 548 exprimé 495 majorité 248 pour
408 contre 87 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
[Applaudissements]